all right so let's move on the dod
released something called an aoi MSG so
what is that and then why are there
questions raised over the redactions
one of the documents that I love to go
for are what are utilized by public
affairs and these are called briefing
cards and various topics will get
internal
um banter on how to respond to questions
on we'll we'll say UFOs or uh something
that's happening in Afghanistan or the
Ukraine or whatever these briefing cards
assist the office of public affairs with
how to answer questions it also allows
them to to know what's unclassified what
is something that we can talk about as a
government without uh harming any
national security because obviously the
The Press Room the journalists if
they're doing their job they're asking
questions that could impede on
classified information so these briefing
cards will really Aid in helping answer
those questions and it really is as
straightforward as them creating uh
hypothetical questions that could be
asked and then you have answers and so
when somebody asks it you'll see this if
you watch a press briefing which are
sometimes pretty snoozy to watch but
when you watch them you'll see them go
in their notebook open up as the
journalist is asking a question reason
being is they have these answers
prepared so you hear a lot of lines over
and over the same way well it's because
they're approved they go through these
approval processes so one of the fun
things to get my hands on are the ones
related to UFOs because it breaks down
the different UFO research efforts it
involves all the different angles of of
journalists asking these questions and
the aoi MSG was one of the few research
efforts that were aimed to investigate
UAP the current one is Arrow but prior
to that was the aoi MSG it stand stood
for the Airborne object identification
and management synchronization group and
when you get these documents it really
gives you a sneak peek into to
what they wanted the public to know and
essentially what the public what they
didn't want the public to know so so
both ends of the spectrum so when I
first got these some of these documents
about two weeks ago what was interesting
was there was no redactions and it just
kind of broke down what the aoi MSG was
it's its approach to UAP why it was
doing it all the stuff we've heard
before was nothing earth-shattering but
then a second request came in about a
week and a half later where it was the
same exact briefing card with the same
exact date but it had more information
to it now the first one did have a
question about extraterrestrials and if
a journalist were to ask about aliens
what was the response and essentially
and I'm paraphrasing here but the dod
was kind of getting away from that topic
they didn't want to talk about it so
they would push the the answer towards
NASA that the dod doesn't look for
aliens and extraterrestrials but NASA
does so essentially trying to say hey go
to them because we're not looking for
for extraterrestrials or aliens uh my
quick argument to that is it doesn't
matter if the dod is looking for aliens
or not if they are truly investigating
UAP and that slim possibility indicates
that there is an extraterrestrial
connection regardless of if they were
looking for it or not they are looking
for the truth right so we don't push
that to NASA we should be able to to
deal with the topic but the dod doesn't
want to there were no redactions in that
first release but in the version that I
got on the the the second release had a
full redacted section after the
Extraterrestrial uh question about
additional talking points and I want to
make sure that I uh quote the the
document correctly but additional
background information and in
parentheses not for release and was
entirely redacted this entire section
the question mark is why now I I want to
put up front it's possible that this
section and this header has nothing to
do with extraterrestrials right that's
right and that's fine right so I want to
make sure that that's that's stated it
may just be a coincidence it comes after
the Extraterrestrial uh question
but the other part of it right
regardless of if it's connected to
extraterrestrials or not what don't they
want us to know in a public affairs
document one key point I may not have
mentioned yet is it's unclassified so
these documents when it comes to public
affairs uh these types of documents are
unclassified so there's no classified
information in it simply because this is
what they want to convey to the public
but in this particular document these
redactions were there the legal
justification when it comes to the
letter of the law states that the dod is
arguing it is deliberative process
information so essentially they're
talking about something internally
and they don't want you to know so that
deliberative process that internal
banter is potentially exempt under foia
that's a technical term deliberative
process delete right so it's
deliberative in nature so the
of the uh phrase that we've used a lot
to reference it's called exemption B5
the phrase that we've used to to
reference this is essentially the exempt
it if you want to
um exemption because they can if they
want to just cite B5 and fall back on
that and there's really no way to fight
it now I have issued an appeal I have
wanted to to fight this which I am and
that's ongoing as we speak but it is
very very hard to to fight B5 exemptions
simply because it doesn't have to be
classified it doesn't have to be a
threat to National Security if they
release it there doesn't have to be an
internal statute that exempts them from
releasing the information no the
reviewer just has to look at it and go
ah it's deliberative let's go ahead and
use B5 and that's why we call it on my
side of the fence not the government
side but my side yeah the exempt it if
you want to uh exemption so it's
frustrating to see but again it begs the
question of if if we really are dealing
with a government that wants to be as
transparent as they can what in a public
affairs document is exempt from
disclosure under B5 and I'm not sure
what that is so hopefully the the appeal
will will yield something uh and we'll
hopefully get more of a glimpse but who
knows I mean it's it's anybody's guess
on if it connected with the
Extraterrestrial connection but very
very fun to think about yeah I wouldn't
say that the government is trying to be
as transparent as they can they claim to
be that they they say they're trying to
be as transparent as they can yeah in
the hearing Scott Bray or Ronald
Moultrie or both they were kind of
saying like look we as long as we don't
have a threat to National Security here
we want to be as transparent with the
public and this that and the other thing
in the most recent hearing so that was
the the first hearing the most uh recent
one uh Dr Sean Kirkpatrick said
something similar and that they were
trying to create a website that people
like you and I can go on from the public
and download information from their UFO
Case Files that they've released to the
public now all that sounds great but
nothing is nothing is happening and
Kirkpatrick said that the upper
essentially the upper echelon at the dod
has the draft of this website in their
hands and has had so since uh the
holiday season of 2022 and has not
approved anything and hasn't launched
anything so what they say in these
hearings are is wildly different than
what they're actually doing
so while the government hasn't been able
to create such a website me and you have
worked behind the scenes to try and
create some indexable natural language
way of searching through your documents
and that website is theblattovault.com
The Black Vault is like 99.9999 of the
work I want to keep letting people know
that I'm just like a hair on the top of
John's head
so it's just saying like hey there's got
to be like you've done all this work
across all these years these decades
like let's find some way to make it even
more accessible using the latest
technology so that's theblacktovall.com
and whether or not that forwards to
another URL that we change it to later
by the time you hear this who knows but
currently that's the website
I'm super excited about that too because
obviously the the buzzwords in today's
society even away from UFOs is AI and
artificial intelligence and how can
those tools utilize be utilized for our
everyday work and I'll be honest with
you I I began utilizing it myself for
things that I do even unrelated to The
Black Vault but it's an incredibly
powerful tool but how can you how can
you take that technology and take that
power and connect it to a database of
3.2 million pages of documents on all
sorts of topics or just the UFO section
what can be done with it I'm really
really eager to see how this plays out
and how the technology
evolves and then how that can uh help us
all with research and and getting
answers and trying to unravel some of
these Mysteries yeah and Dan Daniel the
person you've been speaking with Daniel
VanZant he said Kurt this wouldn't have
even been able to be talked about being
done six months ago like we're using The
Cutting Edge yeah these tools will
continue to evolve and more features
will be added and who knows maybe even
it becomes I would like it to become
open source and transparent in terms of
the algorithm and how it's taking in the
information and processing it yeah and
hopefully someone else takes this over
because like I just I'd like toe
theories of everything and studying math
and physics and this was like a way way
way larger project than I thought yeah
correctly estimated it I don't remember
thinking no it's got to be easier than
that John yeah but you know what's cool
and and on your point and Daniel's point
is that six months ago this wasn't
possible now we're having the
conversation and even though we're
seeing those Road bumps and and kind of
concerns over the amount of data and how
that's going to happen
in a couple months from now six months
or even a year from now you see the
evolution of this technology and in my
mind you really want to have a show that
that how that technology will evolve
itself and I think that there's going to
become a point where all of a sudden you
will run into these roadblocks but the
assistance of AI will help you overcome
those roadblocks themselves so even
though I can't see it with my P brain uh
you know I AI might be able to or create
some kind of algorithm that we could
utilize that we never thought of that's
what's fascinating about it because what
is what is impossible on Monday is
commonplace on Tuesday in this world and
that's what intrigues me the most about
it you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy